i i know what you want chris what i bet
you watched logan paul's fight oh i
watched it yeah yeah
now he's excited mike tyson can i get
your oh i actually have thoughts on all
this boxing [ __ ] that's going on and uh
with like the youtubers and the real
well the youtubers
honestly if you're taking it as
seriously as logan paul and [ __ ] uh
jake paul then you know they deserve a
chance to
box right i mean but like it's clearly a
market for it they're making millions
right no i understand that you're also
training hard for it but i mean that
though i you know i think if there's a
market for it who gives them yeah i
agree yeah but it's if no one's watching
it's like what do you do but it's well
if it's but but my question is and i
don't know much about it but like
the it's really [ __ ] irresponsible
irresponsible is that the word not
irresponsible right yeah but i said that
i put a violence
and you made fun of my speech yeah i
know i know i know i [ __ ] up i [ __ ]
up yeah you didn't try and i own it
no but thank you i appreciate general
general chain around your neck but yeah
die they trained for three years but the
other they're i don't know who they are
they are but some of the guys aren't
right yeah but i would say jake and
logan but the rest of the youtubers that
no one's taking seriously they're
fighting another youtuber so it's like i
know but isn't that dangerous not really
no they're those are
like if you and brian want to fight
that would happen well well well they
well now now though you've got logan
fighting mike tyson i'm i'm amazed at
his he's got balls
he's gutsy
imagine if imagine if calvin's logan
paul right yeah and he's whatever 23
years old he goes dad i'm going to box
i'm this big youtuber i'm going to box
and go all right cool hey and i'm going
to fight floyd mayweather and mike tyson
you'd like you're out of your [ __ ]
smaller much smaller mike tyson has the
power to knock you still knock you into
the next but chuck liddell made a good
point uh when he's on food drinking
watching now available now on uh
uh chuck liddell said uh he goes
he goes because i go would you fight
logan paul goes i would fight him but
it'd be a fight like i'm i'm gonna fight
him i'm not gonna do this glorified yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and he was like
with mike tyson how do you see that
going down he uses it's a glorified
sparring match because tyson's not going
to go crazy well if you look at what
tyson and roy jones like that wasn't a
real fight no no they're older guys and
they didn't really hit to the house
right right so he's like i would like he
was i'll watch it but i'd love to see if
tyson actually like brought the real
fight to him well also tyson's about 55.
he doesn't get a bit of it if he but if
he gets close and he that that that's
sort of like it does matter though
because if the rules are and i'm saying
these are the rules but the rules are oh
wow i know no knockouts to the head not
no you know no you know okay i didn't
know they were gonna have rules like
that i don't i'm not saying they do have
rules like that but chuck point was it's
glorified sparring like they're not
trying to take each other out he's like
i'm down to do it but i'm gonna try and
take him out yeah
yeah i think uh either way but jake's
but see logan and jake are different
yeah logan's going for the biggest
payday the most views the floyd
mayweathers mike tyson's chance on when
that fight's not good right so for him
just to survive as a win for him he
makes all the best
you know his fight against tommy fury
like tommy fury is a real professional
boxer i respect that like tyrone
woodley's an actual professional fighter
in the national park but that's so
different than boxing isn't it well
tywin woodley is no joke
with a hall of fame yeah woodley hasn't
been asking yeah that's different
because he's not a striker in any
fashion
jake paul is serious about it and and i
respect i think he's not so hard
i i do respect that and logan paul these
guys they have a work ethic they have
that that midwest farm boy work ethic
they work their ass off well and they're
smart business big and athletic and
strong yeah athletic too
i saw i saw logan the other day he was
he was at the laugh factory and and and
we you know we were like hey what's up
and and he had that
like that
it was like a brand yeah you know what i
mean like when you shake a fighter's
hand
it was like uh yeah it's like a it was
really he'd keep you busy chris yeah
he'd keep you busy well if if you guys
talk i don't want to fight dude you know
what i mean
what would you say
what are you saying i went on a show i
was like dude you would love him yeah
did he do it no we're buds he he uh but
that was just jokes and honestly i
i you know
it was fun